hi everyone so yeah today I'm gonna talk
about a couple of CSS fun facts that
I've collected over the years the kind
of things that were interesting to me
when I finally did understand them or
took me a very long time to figure out
and it is my hope that some of these
things are new to you or at least that
they are entertaining in some way and
I'm sure that at the end of the talk
you'll agree that CSS is much more
powerful and even more beautiful than
what we end up using it for in our day
to day jobs so first let me just quickly
introduce myself hi I'm Matthias I work
for Opera Software in developer
relations and before that I used to
freelance as a web developer a front-end
web developer so you could say I have
been dealing with CSS for a lot of years
now I like web standards in general
programming web security and working on
open source projects now if you have any
questions at all during this talk like
if you're watching the live stream or
whatever or watching this video later
just send me a message on twitter my
handle is just my first name Mattias and
I'll be sure to get back to you of
course if you're here today just come
talk to me afterwards and I'll be happy
to answer any questions you have now
let's get started let's start off with
everyone's favorite CSS feature
important yeah I'm sure you're all
familiar with what important does right
in a situation like this for example all
the elements with class bar get the
green color but all the elements with
class bar within an element with class
foo get a red color I'm sure I'm not
telling you anything new here and that
looks something like this so whenever
there is a conflict between two
selectors in CSS then by default the
last one in the source code wins but in
this case the specificity for both
selectors is different the one with the
highest specificity wins regardless of
the order in the source code so here the
specificity of the first selector with
the two class selectors in it is
actually higher than the specificity of
the last one and that's why the color is
red and not green again I'm sure this is
nothing new to you now in some
situations you may need to override an
earlier rule set so in this case you
want all elements with class bar to be
green despite of that other
is rule at the top there and it's cases
like this where important can be useful
you can just add importance to that last
statement there and it boosts that
single declaration precedents in CSS so
if you do that then the color in fact
will become green and again I'm sure
this is nothing new to you you know how
important works right
well what one surprised me here is that
important actually has nothing to do at
all with specificity it's actually a
completely different thing it boosts a
single declarations precedence without
affecting the specificity for the whole
selector now you may have heard that to
use of important is actually a bad
practice so you're not actually supposed
to be using it even though sometimes we
all do now the good news is now that we
know that there's a difference between
specificity and the use of importance we
can actually fake importance we can use
important without using importance and
instead of boosting the declarations
precedence we can just increase the
selector specificity so all we have to
do is just repeat the class name in the
last lecture a couple of hundred times
and every time you do that you boost the
selector specificity so if you just do
that enough times automatically this
selector will eventually win and just to
show you that this actually works it
does and in this case we only need to
repeat the class name once if it's twice
there if it's there twice it will be the
strongest one the specificity will be
highest and it will win so there you
have it I know it's still early in the
morning but already we've established
our new best practice of the day yay
not really okay so let's talk about farm
family names and CSS now let's do a show
of hands if you've heard this one before
if there's whitespace in the font family
name it must be quoted no no one is
certain before okay I got this off the
w3c CSS validator it used to give this
message to anywhere when you had some
CSS like this one font family come comic
sans ms and you forgot the quotes around
it it would give you the warning hey you
should you're supposed to be quoting
this so for a very long time I was
afraid of having white space in font
family names without using quotes around
it
but a couple of years later I actually
found out that this doesn't really make
a lot of sense at all spaces are not
problematic and found family names
usually if the font family name is a
space separated set of CSS identifiers
there's no problem at all
so if you want to use Comic Sans a mess
you don't actually need the codes the
CSS will still be valid and it will
still work exactly the same way in all
browsers now there's a lot of exact
rules and description and exceptions
here if you want you can check out the
URL in the middle of this slide for all
the details but trust me when I say that
in this case we can simply omit the
quotes and everything will still work
exactly the same way in fact there are
other things that are much more
dangerous than whitespace in film family
names here's an example let's say we
have a Fonz named 4 5 6 . street now
because this film family name starts
with a digit it's no longer of valid CSS
identifiers so this rule won't actually
silently be ignored it's not valid CSS
now the way to fix that is to make it a
valid identifier and we can do that by
escaping that first digit there and that
will look something like this now we get
backslash 3 4 5 6 . street and that's
kind of weird right because the font
family name is 4 5 6 birria street but
now it says 3 4 5 6 and there's a space
and there's a backslash and it's all
just a little bit crazy and this is
probably not code that you want to be
writing or maintaining now how else can
we resolve this problem well of course
you guessed it we can just use quotes
around the font family name so whenever
you're in doubt I would say just always
use the quotes it avoids a lot of
problems and it's you know it that way
you don't have to think about all these
issues that might pop up but the thing I
learned here is that there is no need to
use the quotes just because of
whitespace that's just not true now I
really wanted to understand how all this
works and so I ended up making a small
tool for it so you can enter any font
family name in there and it will tell
you if it can be used without the quotes
in CSS or not now let's take a closer
look at attribute values in HTML and CSS
as you probably know in both HTML CSS we
can use quotes around
tribute failures I'm sure that's not big
news for you
so here we have an anchor element with
an HR f of foo and then in the CSS style
block we select that same element based
on its attribute value and then we give
it a nice hot pink background now in
some cases like in this example we can
actually omit these quotes and
everything still works fine the HTML is
still valid the CSS is still valid and
the result looks the same in every
browser there's no problems whatsoever
however it's important to note that the
rules for unquoted
attribute values actually differ between
HTML and CSS in this example the HTML is
valid the attribute value is through
pipe bar but the CSS actually is invalid
in this case and it won't work it will
actually silently be ignored and there
will no be no beautiful hot pink in this
example at all so how do we resolve this
again you guessed it all you have to do
is just use the quotes and in this case
it's only really necessary to use quotes
for the CSS version but in general the
same advice holds it's probably best to
just always wrap your attribute values
in quotes both in HTML and in CSS
because it's that way you just don't
have to think about all these potential
issues and about the difference between
HTML and CSS rules I really wanted to
understand this as well so and all these
real differences between HTML and CSS so
I ended up making another tool and you
can enter any value it will instantly
tell you if it can be used as an
uncrowded
attribute value in HTML and in CSS and
as you can see in some cases the result
is actually different between these two
languages okay another thing I learned
something new about is CSS comment as
you probably know this is the only
common syntax that CSS sports it starts
with a slash followed by an asterisk and
then it ends with an asterisk followed
by another slash and anything in between
those two things will become part of a
comment even if it's like a newline
character so it becomes it can become a
multi-line comments that way now that's
why this example works the way you
expect it to the color colon rats rule
it won't up be affected
it will silently big nor because it's
part of a commons now lots of other
programming language have another
comment line syntax as well this is the
single line comments index and it uses
just two slashes and everything else on
the same line will be ignored in that
case however CSS doesn't support this
syntax it doesn't have the concept of
single line comments so this is actually
invalid CSS
however what surprised me about this is
that this specific example would
actually work the way we'd expect it to
the line with color : rat
will not have any effect so what's going
on there well it turns out that property
names in CSS are supposed to be valid
CSS identifiers and identifiers cannot
contain unescape slashes and because of
that this one rule fails to parse and
CSS just skips it moves on to the next
one and then applies that now it would
be different if the property name that
we're using was a valid identifier
because then the CSS would be parsed
just fine however CSS grammar also
states that rules for unknown properties
are silently ignored so this gives us
another way to fake a single line
comment in CSS we could just use the
British spelling or we could just make
some typos in the property name and
that's kind of crazy and you should
never deliberately do this probably but
it kind of works in the sense that the
rule is silently ignored now tap Atkins
has an excellent blog post that explains
these tricks and it's a good way to
learn a little bit about CSS grammar and
about how CSS error handling works so
check it out there's something else
that's related to CSS that I would like
to show you but before I can do that we
need to talk about HTML tags for a
little while now does anyone know the
difference between HTML tags and
elements let's do a quick show of hands
okay not a lot of people are confident
in the difference so I'll just briefly
explain it tags are the things that you
type into your code editor when you're
editing an HTML page so for example if
you have a paragraph element on your
page you can have a star tag to open the
paragraph element and an end tag to
close that P elements those are tags but
as soon as your document is part
by the browser it becomes a Dom a
document object model it becomes this
tree based thing that you interact with
in JavaScript or in CSS and once that
happens we no longer think in terms of
start and end tags we think in terms of
elements so that's pretty much
difference as soon as the page is open
in the browser its elements and melt
tags that we're thinking about and
that's important to realize because if
you're dealing with CSS or JavaScript
you're always interacting with these
elements not with tags or star tags or
end tags so anyway here's an example
this is a very simple HTML document so
you see the HTML and the head and the
body tags there well it turns out that
they're closing tags their end tags are
optional you can just omit them and the
result is a compact but still valid HTML
document that results in exactly the
same Dom as the one before but it gets
even better it turns out that you can
also omit their start tags for these
elements and that way you end up with
this very minimal but still valid HTML
document that still results in exactly
the same Dom so that's really important
here the HTML the hat and the body
elements will still be there in the Dom
even though they're Clark techs are
omitted from the source code and that's
because these elements are special
they're kind of implied and the browser
will automatically insert them into the
document for you even if they're not
part of the source code so with that in
mind this is probably the most useless -
to ever I mean if you're going to get an
HTML - at least you should pick some
tags that aren't implies right now
anyway that minimal HTML document that I
just showed you got me thinking how far
can we really take this and what more
can we remove from our HTML source code
if we stop caring about what's valid and
what isn't and then I came across Martin
Cole's experiment called no JavaScript
so he attempted to recreate a game using
CSS only and his goal was to use no
JavaScript at all and as little as HTML
as little HTML as possible and in fact
this is the full HTML source code for
his project it's just one line that
includes a stylesheet
on to the page
and really you should check this out for
yourself the URL is right there but just
to give you a quick idea of what it
looks like well here it is so remember
this is all CSS and I'm not sure if you
can see this but the spaceship at the
bottom is actually following my mouse
cursor which sounds simple if you have
the other script axis but if you want to
do this using only CSS it's actually
very tricky now the elements that are
being styled here are the ones that
we've talked about before the ones that
the browser automatically creates for
you even if they're not part of the
source code
so HTML hat and body and then there's
also that one link element that he had
there in the source code so of course
the link and the hat elements are
invisible by default but you can just
apply this play block to them to make
them visible then you can start styling
them giving them a background image and
all that stuff so anyway we have HTML
hat link and body that's four different
elements then we can also use the before
and after pseudo elements on these
elements and that totals up to twelve
unique style blocks so what you're
looking at here is just twelve unique
style blocks and that's enough to create
this apparently it's kind of crazy and
it just really blew my mind still demo
so I created a demo of my own it's not
nearly as impressive as this one but I
still want to talk about it this is what
it looks like yeah I know right it's not
nearly as impressive to look at that as
the previous one but it looks fairly
simple and if I were to see this on a
random website I would probably think it
was just some basic HTML like a
paragraph element or something and with
some very basic CSS to style it but in
fact if you look at the source code for
this page you'll see that it's
completely empty so what is going on
here well this is the trick that I used
I'm using the link HTTP header here so
in theory this header can be used
instead of the link element in HTML
anything you can do with the link
element in HTML can also be done with
the link HTTP header in browsers that
support it and at the moment only
Firefox supported supports it's Oprah I
used to support it
before we switch to blank but ever since
we brought support so if you want to try
this out visit this page in Firefox so
anyway this gives us a completely empty
HTML documents as you can see the
content length is zero so I'm not
cheating there I'm not using any special
weird tricks it's really an empty HTML
document but we still get a CSS file
applied to it so the next step is to
make the document look like it contains
some actual text and for this I used two
CSS content property so I select the
body element which the browser
automatically creates for me even though
I don't have the tag for it in the
source code then I target the after
pseudo element and then I just give that
some contents and that's how I made the
texture up there so that is how this
demo without any HTML source code at all
works now is this really useful well I
don't know maybe you can prank your
colleagues with this knowledge a little
bit or if you're really evil you could
use it as part of an interview question
imagine this so you give an interview
candidate URL and tell them to open it
in Firefox and this URL points to an
HTML document that contains some inline
SVG for example the SVG that displays a
circle as you can see here now the
circles fill attribute is set to red and
that's when you ask the interview
candidate why is the circle green
instead of red and it will probably take
them very long time to realize that
there's a hidden CSS file that magically
gets applied to these documents even
though you can't see it in the source
code I mean the Styles are not even
visible if you inspect the elements in
the dev tools so yeah good luck with
that I hope none of that ever happens to
you in an interview ok if you want to
talk about Unicode in CSS we need to
talk about Unicode in HTML too so let's
start there the first thing you should
know is that the class attribute accepts
every possible character every possible
unicode character is valid in a class
attribute value and it will also work in
every browser so for example 404 - ever
is a valid class name which is probably
not very surprising to you but you could
also use the copyright sign as a class
name for an element containing a legal
disclaimer
for example now in html5 in the standard
there is this new feature that says that
the same thing now finally goes for the
ID attributes so this is new and aspect
with browser as I've always supported
this
this means that IDs can contain any
symbol at all except for whitespace but
everything else is valid as part of an
ID attribute so you could use the heart
symbol as the ID for a paragraph for
example or you could use curly quotes as
a class name for block code elements you
can do all kinds of stuff you can even
use hidden emoji to passive-aggressively
tell people you are using a shitty
browser and all of this is valid HTML
this also means that we can do stuff
like this where you give an element an
ID of hash ID or let's say a class of
adult class or you can even combine it
to an ad colon hover braces at the end
or even use a value that resembles an
attribute selector you see where this is
going right all these classes and ID's
already look like they're a CSS selector
so how would you write as use a selector
to select these elements based on these
IDs and classes well the answer is we
need to escape these values first so
that they become valid identifier and
only then we can use them as part of a
CSS selector and this is what that will
look like the hash symbol for example
has special meaning in CSS so it cannot
be used as it is we must escape it as
backslash hash first and the same thing
goes for the dot character has special
meaning so that becomes backslash dot
the colon character leads escaping too
and theoretically you could escape that
as backslash colon but that doesn't work
in old versions of Internet Explorer so
a more compatible way to escape it is to
use backslash 3 a followed by a space
and 3 a is the unicode code point that
refers to this character so you could
use this type of escape for any Unicode
symbol if you want to anyway as you can
see many characters need escaping but
take a look at that last example the
element with ID 404 - error because that
ID starts with a digit it needs to be
escaped as well
and I remember that this really
surprised me at some point because I was
trying to figure out why it was
impossible to style such an element
using CSS well it turned out I just had
to escape it and that looks like
backslash three for space oh four dash
error which is kind of weird if you
think about it
so if you'd ever need to style an
element whose class or ID starts with a
digit I'm sure you will think back on
this moment because it took me a long
time to figure this out now as for the
other examples with the non ASCII
Unicode symbols well those can just be
used without escaping them at all
because they don't have any special
meaning in CSS now you could still
escape them if you wanted to based on
the Unicode code point value and that
will look like this now to help me
understand all this I built another one
of those tools so it allows you to enter
any ID or class name even the crazy ones
and then it will automatically tell you
how to select that element in CSS or
using the selectors API in JavaScript so
if you're using documental career
selector or jQuery or something like
that
it will tell you what the selector would
look like after the double escaping that
you need for that nowadays there's a
standardized utility method for this in
the form of a JavaScript API called CSS
escape and this is part of the CSS
object model specification it's already
two supported in Opera Chrome and
Firefox so you can actually already
start using this today if you need
support for older browsers as well
there's a polyfill available that you
can use now the thing is you probably
need this functionality much more often
than you would think and here's some
examples of that I'm sure many of you
have just some I've done something like
this at some point I know I have so you
read the hash from the URL and then you
use it to select an element in
JavaScript this is fairly common if you
use a taps widget on your page for
example so look at this code and imagine
what happens if the location hash
contains a space for example now the
entire meaning of the selector that we
dynamically generate would suddenly
change because instead of selecting an
element based on that ID it would now
become a descendant selector now here's
another example
very dynamically construct a CSS
selector what if some value in this case
contains double quotes the CSS selector
would actually be broken because the
attribute selector would be closed by
the double quote this might throw a
javascript error and otherwise break
your site so this code is actually
broken but it's not really obvious to
see that now how can we avoid these
problems well all we need to do is just
wrap the variable parts of these
selectors in a call to CSS dot escape
and that magically makes it work and
protects against these cases now that
we're on the subject of breaking things
using malformed CSS selectors let's take
a look at how CSS can be used for evil
now first we need to talk about
cross-site scripting or XSS has anyone
ever heard of that before okay yeah some
people some evil hackers in the room
even if you have heard of cross-site
scripting I would recommend checking out
Google's cross-site scripting game it's
a really great way to learn about how
these cross-site scripting attacks work
and how you can exploit them yourself
and actually if you give this a try you
would be surprised how simple it is to
perform these attacks yourself now most
websites nowadays contain display or
they display use of supplied contents in
different contexts within an HTML
document so here a custom user color is
inserted in the context of a CSS value
then the user name is inserted in an
HTML text context as part of a paragraph
element the user profile URL is injected
in a quoted HTML attribute value the
user ID is inserted in a JavaScript
context on the right hand side of a
variable declaration and finally some
server generated debug information is
inserted as part of a comments in HTML
so all of these things are variable
content which can somehow be controlled
or at least influenced by the user and
the website that displays this
information in the HTML code needs to
make sure that the user input is
properly sanitized and escaped for the
context that it gets inserted to and
that is the main problem
each of these five different contexts
requires its own different escaping
rules so usually web application hackers
look for cross-site scripting
vulnerabilities which enable them to
execute custom JavaScript code in the
context of the targeted website once
they found such a vulnerability they can
basically do anything they want in
JavaScript to that website so the hacker
could add a script that listens for
keyboard events for example and then
logs whatever you like it locks your
keystrokes that the victim enters to
their own server for example it would
essentially be a key logger or it could
just read sensitive information from the
Dom and then leaked it to the attacker
server so that they basically steal that
data now that's using JavaScript but
this is a CSS conference so let's shift
our perspective here what can we do if
we have full control over pages CSS but
nothing else
what's the worst thing we can do as an
evil hacker in that case in other words
what if all these injections that we
talked about are all sanitized properly
except for the first one this one so for
the sake of the example assume that
there is some sort of sanitation going
on there that makes it impossible to
close this tile element in the HTML but
everything else is allowed to you can
inject any CSS you want but you cannot
inject arbitrary HTML what damage can
you do with that well does anyone
remember the CSS Zen garden yeah some
people if you look this up you'll end up
at this website it's just a very simple
HTML document and it can be styled using
CSS and anything is anyone is free to
contribute a CSS file with a custom
design and if it looks good it will be
added to the site so here's a bunch of
different designs designs there's over
200 on this website already and they all
look beautiful and completely different
and the main thing here is that the only
thing that is really changing between
these designs is the CSS the HTML is
exactly the same for every page that you
see here so this is a very powerful
demonstration of what CSS can do
now if you look at this from the
perspective of an evil hacker imagine
having that kind of power over a website
that you're targeting the obvious thing
to do as an evil hacker is of course to
completely deface the website you can
make it look like at whatever you want
basically so here's the original CSS
comp website for example now if you had
full control over the CSS but nothing
else you could make it look like this
and I'm not sure they would sell any
tickets this way because it's a CSS
conference and you have you know some
certain expectations about their use of
CSS so when an attacker is able to
control the CSS of your page in such a
way that's probably or not what you want
it could be even worse I mean they could
just hide all the existing content and
then just apply a background image that
contains some text of their own for
example so they could basically replace
all the existing content of the site
with whatever they want there's
something else that you could do and
this is kind of similar to defacing but
it's much more subtle you wouldn't touch
the design but you would just inject
some really annoying CSS rules and
there's a project that collects CSS
rules like that it's called evil dot CSS
and it's just a CSS file basically with
a bunch of really annoying CSS rules it
also contains some rules that are just
super bad for performance just for the
fun of it and yeah again here's the
original CSS deaf West web site and
here's that same web site with evil dot
CSS enables so there's no extra scroll
bars everywhere the layout is slightly
broken some of the content is flickering
or missing the text is slightly blurry
I'm not sure how easy to see that is
yeah there's a lot of content just
missing suddenly
scrolling also feels really really slow
because of all those terrible
performance-wise CSS that is added to
the page and my favorite part is the
first letter in each element is slightly
smaller than all the other ones so
annoying
anyway so both defacing and doing this
sort of thing to web sites can be
annoying for both the administrators and
the visitors of the web site but it
could be much worse right because if we
look back at cross-site scripting
well you could steal sensitive
information that way and this is not
possible using just TSS right or is it
well let's see
CSS kind of allows you to leak the value
for any attribute value in the Dom so
some attribute values contain security
sensitive information like a CSRF token
for example now if you were an attacker
or a hacker you wanted to steal this
value attribute here using nothing but
CSS injection how would you go about it
well one way to do it is to write a
bunch of CSS like this you could use the
CSS attribute starts with selector and
that way it's trivial to figure out the
first character of the CSRF token just
by brute forcing it you just try every
possible value for that first character
and you include a unique background
image URL on your own server for each
character and when the browser makes the
request to your server you know that
that character matches and then you can
start doing the same thing for the first
two characters to guess the second
character and so on until you have brute
force the entire token so in the worst
case scenario you could just enumerate
all the possible values for the CSRF
token but in practice you don't really
need to test all of them it's a bit
faster than that and here's an actual
proof of concept for this sort of attack
it doesn't use any JavaScript at all so
only a lot of CSS rules and it's not
very efficient or fast but it shows that
it is possible to actually exfiltrate
the sensitive data this way by using
nothing but CSS now that was about
stealing information that was hidden in
an HTML attribute what if you want to
steal data from the Dom that is part of
a text node using nothing but CSS so
let's say we have some HTML like this
that contains let's say a username or
something else that we want to find out
or maybe it's the balance of your bank
accounts something like that but you
can't use JavaScript you can only use
CSS injection how can we do this well
you could use Unicode range to define
web fonts to be used only for specific
character
so if you create a separate Fontes
declaration for each individual
character with a unique URL for each
font you can essentially figure out
which characters are being used as part
of the CSS content and here's a proof of
concept of that the demo was made by a
guy named masato Kanagawa and as you can
see the browser makes a request for each
of the characters that is being used
as part of this sensitive content now
one downside is that it wouldn't show
you the repeated characters like for
example the letter a is being used three
times in this case and of course the
browser will only make one request for
the font that is used for the letter A
but in many cases like it really depends
on the use case of course but in many
cases just knowing which characters are
being used is enough to guess the rest
now still it could be worse there could
be an easy way to steal sensitive data
that is fast it's efficient that doesn't
require us to write a lots of CSS and it
turns out there is such a thing as well
and CSS ie5 introduced this proprietary
feature called CSS expressions to make
it possibly to dynamically calculate the
values for certain CSS properties and
this feature was supported up until I 7
now even if you've never seen this
before if you just look at the syntax
closely you'll note that the code
wrapped in the expression part is
actually JavaScript so yes these as
expressions are basically a way to run
JavaScript in your CSS it's a great idea
I'm not sure what could possibly go
wrong here
anyway because it's all just JavaScript
it means you can use browser specific
JavaScript methods as well like alert
for example this example would show an
alert message and that looks something
like this but it also means you can use
Dom related methods like window that
open so you can actually open a new
window with the URL of our choice using
nothing but CSS and that of course could
be the URL for a malicious web site like
a phishing website that pretends to be
the original website and then asks you
for your password
soon as you enter it of course the
attacker has stolen your password now
you may be thinking okay this really
sucks but if this only affects i7 and
older versions of ie then what's the big
deal no one really supports those
browsers anymore and not a lot of people
use IE 7 well that's true but the thing
is Internet Explorer has this thing
called browser modes and the last four
major IE releases each shipped multiple
rendering engines that emulated the bugs
in their older IE versions their f12
developer tools allow you to easily
switch between them now that's all good
but it's also possible to trigger a
specific rendering mode for your website
by using an HTTP header or an HTML meta
elements the meta tag on this slide
ensures that your document is rendered
in the latest available rendering mode
so this means that if someone using ie
11 visits your site it will render it
using the OEE 11 rendering mode which as
a developer is probably what you want
and I tend to use ie 10 mode in IE 9 to
use ie 9 mode that makes sense however
this meta tag would trigger i7 mode even
in ie8 or I 9 or I 10 and the thing is
this mode not only emulates the known
bugs that i7 used to have but it also
brings back the old deprecated or even
removed features that i7 used to have
such as CSS expressions so our initial
example it only worked in i7 and older
versions can be made to work even in IE
8 9 and 10 just by adding a meta tag it
even works in AI 11 if the site is in
the so called trust its own so that's
why I did I include ie 11 in the title
here because it's a little bit trickier
so okay that's pretty cool but in our
attack scenario from before we could
only inject CSS and we couldn't inject
HTML so we had no way to add the meta
tag there so how can we still make use
of this trick well it turns out that the
attacker can just create a web page of
their own hosted on their own server at
the meta tag there and trigger ie7
compatibility mode and then they could
embed the targeted website with their
CSS payload inside of an iframe
in that case the documents the document
mode of the parent document is inherited
by the targeted website in the iframe
even if the targeted website would
normally use the latest available
rendering mode so this allows the
attacker to use CSS expressions in the
context of the target website even in
ie10
so just to recap there's two conditions
here if a target website allows you to
inject arbitrary CSS and it allows
framing then this enables attackers to
perform cross-site scripting attacks on
your site and Internet Explorer using
nothing but CSS I thought that was kind
of crazy now what can you do about this
how can we avoid these CSS expression
vulnerabilities as a web web site
administrator well of course all of this
can be avoided if you just sanitize all
your intrusted input before injecting it
into your HTML responses all you have to
do is never make a single mistake and
everything will be fine sure like that's
ever going to happen
so failing that you could use the X
frame options HTTP header to prohibit
framing of your web page and this makes
it impossible for an attacker to easily
pick your page into i7 compatibility
mode and thereby enable CSS expressions
and last but not least and this is
another thing that really surprised me
you could use the so-called html5
doctype you know the short one and it
turns out that Internet Explorer uses
this doctype as a heuristic whenever a
page is rendered using this doctype it
will automatically disable CSS
expressions even if your page gets
framed and inherits the i7 document mode
CSS expressions won't work with this
doctype and this is not true for any
other dog type so if you have a lot of
old HTML pages on your server lying
around that you don't even maintain
anymore it's definitely a good idea to
just do a simple search replace on them
and just update their doctype to use
this one it won't break anything and
will actually make your site more secure
in Internet Explorer so to me this is
really kind of crazy to think about
because you need to add an HTTP header
and use a specific duck type in your
HTML just to prevent people from running
JavaScript in your CSS well
it's a bit too much for me really but
that's the Internet Explorer I guess now
it's not just ie there's other browsers
that used to have books with JavaScript
and CSS you can kind of execute
JavaScript using nothing but CSS in
other browsers like old versions of
Firefox used to have a bug if you assign
a background image to an element and
point it to a JavaScript URL the script
would be executed however it would be
executed in a sandbox so it was not
possible to actually steal any data from
the Dom or do anything really malicious
but what you could do is for example
trigger an infinite loop and that would
essentially hang Firefox so if someone
was able to inject this CSS into your
page someone would try to visit the site
in Firefox they would basically just get
this yeah well it would look like this
and then if we just crash now fire from
Mozilla has since fixed the bug so this
is not a problem anymore but it really
makes you think about how powerful CSS
is okay and because I know it's still
early and I've just been talking about a
lot of random different things let's do
a quick CSS quiz who is up for that yeah
oh yeah that's the spirit okay so what
band is this I hope you like music you
can just shout if you want to guess
could be yeah that's the one the Black
Keys yeah these guys okay next one what
band is this you can just shout your
guesses it's fine to guess
what color is that foo fight oh that
would be good no it's not that
it's actually simply rat yeah it's just
ref that was a terrible one okay let's
try another one what band is this this
requires some knowledge of the Unicode
standard yeah its Radiohead okay one
more
what band is this I think someone said
it already yeah the white stripes
alright okay now let's try a song the
famous pop song what song is this yep
painted black by the Rolling Stones like
if you have a red door and CSS you want
to paint it black you can use CSS blend
modes for that turns out okay what band
is this yep Green Day wow that was quick
respect okay let's try some more
editor's yeah that one might have been a
little bit too geeky okay one last one
before I go what band is this yep it's
the Black Eyed Peas
there they are
okay so with that I'd like to thank you
for your attention
and thanks to everyone whose research
I've been using
you